okay I think we'll start welcome to this
talk about fussing with AFL this will be
a kind of introductory talk - fussing so
if you're already a AFL expert you won't
get that much out of it I think a little
bit about myself I work at a company
called Blanc in Oslo I usually do
development but also some security
testing security architecture brontë
stuff and I build open-source security
tools and I'm also head of the OS Norway
chapter I had been wanting to get into a
first thing for quite some time because
I had a lot of colleagues and friends
that were doing fussing but I never
really got around to it until I did a an
online course I guess about a year ago
it was two guys from lift security and
they didn't online training about
fussing native nodejs modules and that
really inspired me to get started with
fussing and it's actually quite fun to
do and it's something that can be really
useful for making robust applications so
the problem with with testing when we
normally write tests ourselves as
developers we know the code so we know
what the code is supposed to do and we
kind of tend to think in that way when
we write our tests we write a lot of
happy path tests and then we try to be
smart and clever and write some tests
that test the edge cases but we tend to
forget some things and then we have the
testers and a lot of testers they are
quite smart at doing all kinds of edge
cases and work things like this but they
don't necessarily know the code so they
don't know what the coach should do or
could do so there's or some of them do
of course there are different types of
testers different types of developers
but again we're going to test a set of
the actual inputs we might have some
oblique ode like this there and the more
branches we had this might be deep down
in some parser somewhere we might have a
lot of different branches so if we were
to like draw out the entire set of
branches in our application it would
look something like this because there
would be a lot of different ways that we
could get to different paths in our code
and what we want to do is try to test as
many of these as possible and see if we
can find make our application crash in
some way and this is what fussing can
help us with often we use code coverage
as a way to figure out how much of the
code that we've been testing with code
coverage is not necessarily the same as
path coverage like the lines might have
been marked as green but we haven't
tested these two green bits at the same
time we might have tested one of them in
one test and one of them in another test
and we don't necessarily know that we
have tested everything this is why code
coverage is not necessarily a good
measure for how well tested our code is
it just tells us which code isn't tested
so fussing first thing is generally the
idea of throwing a lot of input at an
application and see how it responds so
we could we could do this all night long
if we can get a computer to do it so
Craig Young who's done a talk on AFL
earlier at B sides is that you can find
bugs in you in your sleep because you
don't have to do it anymore you can make
the computer do it which is nice and
I've been doing this for quite some time
now finding bugs in my sleep so basic
fussing we could just take the random
and pipe it into the application and see
what's happening and this might actually
work for some applications but it's also
kind of a stupid fussing because if we
get a crash we don't necessarily know
what caused the application to crash
which input was it that made the
application crash and we might run the
same thing all over and over again so we
might get hard to reproduce bugs like we
knew the application crashed at some
point Jerry Knight but we have no idea
what what what was going on so we can
get some smarter fuzzers so we can get a
mutational fuzzer and a mutational for
us sir we'll take a valid input like a
valid file of some kind like if this was
an image parser we could take a valid
image and then we could flick bits or
relocate data within this image and see
how the application responds this is of
course a lot more effective than random
but we still have no insight into what's
going on inside the application we might
try the same thing over and over again
and try and so we're fast and we're
trying and we're testing but we're just
testing the same thing we don't know
what's really going on inside the
application
there's also something called a grammar
fuzzer and with a grammar faster we're
typically then testing the application
with some type of grammar this could be
a protocol or this could be a way to to
handle some type of text or input of
some kind and then we have to kind of
define rules for how this input can be
changed and this can be really good for
for for like really structured data but
it can also be quite hard to get it
right because we need to have a lot of
knowledge to build and configure the
parser correctly so what if we could
just have a buzzer that would look
inside our application and then apply
inputs at the same time that would be
really nice so we wouldn't have to come
up with everything up front so we have
something called a feedback based buzzer
so with the feedback based processor
we're going to use coverage so we're
going to compile in or add in
instrumentation into the application and
so the buzzer can talk to the running
binary and see which branches are being
hit and then it can mutate the input and
then you can see what what happens if I
mutate this input and by doing that it
can know when it's doing the same thing
all over again and it can stop doing
that and it can start muting mutating
something else instead which makes it a
lot more efficient so this is a bit
slower because we have to have the
instrumentation in place and we have to
we have to compile things and do things
in a little bit of a different manner
but of course the effectiveness is
higher because we're removing all these
repetitions that we might be doing if we
were just doing like one of the other
types of buzzers so the best best result
we is we get if we use we actually
compile the application we have the
source code available and we compile in
the instrumentation we can also with AFL
we can add it later to a binary if we
want to
so AFL AFL was developed by a guy called
Michael Saluki who works at Google his
inspiration for building it I think came
from some stuff that Tavis Ormandy of
Google was was doing and it's open
source
and it's quite cleverly made I have to
say I'm no C or C++ expert at all so I
can't vouch for the code but I've been
using it to test code and it's let's say
highly effective and this is a Hall of
Fame from the AFL website where it is
there a lot of these like you can see
Firefox you can see iOS kernel you can
see MySQL you can see all kinds of of
applications and and the OSS and things
like that where AFL has found
vulnerabilities by by fussing so it has
quite a good reputation for finding
finding Hart or finding bugs basically
in everything that's written in C or C++
this picture is from a blog post written
by the the author of FL where he created
an empty file or not an empty file the
file said hello
that was the input so it wasn't the
valid JPEG and then he started fussing
that file and for a widow with a JPEG
parser and eventually because a FL is so
smart it would eventually start
producing valid JPEG images just
starting from the string hello so we
don't have to even give it a valid input
but of course that makes it faster if we
can give it a proper startup but we
could just give it an empty file and it
would actually eventually figure out how
to make in this case a valid JPEG
installing it is fairly easy you just
download it compile it and it's super
fast its small I think it's like 53
kilobytes or something and then you have
what you need you need you might need
some dependencies here like if you're
gonna use the LLVM mode you need LLVM
config and things like that but it's
generally really fast to download
install and then you're up and running
you can't fuss things that are non x86
as well because the instrumentation is
in LLVM mode is supposed to be a CPU
independent I have never tried it but I
know a lot of you are probably working
in the embedded space so it's it it is
supposed to be possible to fuss things
that aren't x86 so the workflow of
fussing something is we
to compile the binary or we could
instrument an existing binary but
usually I will compile the binary with
AFL I will then find a test corpus like
a set of test files that I can use I'll
run the faster which is of course the
thing that takes the most time then
triage the findings figure out what
happened what was happening here what
caused the crashes and things like that
and then maybe there's some profit at
the end but before all of this we need
to get some hardware and when I wanted
to start the first thing I was thinking
well what what kind of hardware do I
actually need and usually it's good to
have a like a multi-core CPU and a
decent amount of RAM so I started poking
around and I asked some friends and they
said well you cannot use like a cloud
VPS you can't go to to digitalocean or
or abs and then just buy every VPS
because they usually don't allow you to
run at a hundred percent CPU all the
time because of course they over commit
on CPU that's the part of the deal so if
you run your VPS on 100% CPU for an
extended period of time they're going to
reboot it and eventually if you keep
doing that they're going to kick you out
so what I did instead I went to a
company called hetner and I rented a
server there and I'm paying I think it's
20 euros per month for this which i
think is a fairly decent price I was
actually thinking of buying something
and putting it in my house but then I
saw the prices here and because what
they're doing is like they're taking
servers that have been used by their
clients that are not using them anymore
and then they're like they're renting
them for for cheap price for from so you
can find something there I actually paid
more but then I found a new server that
was exactly the same specs but with a
cheaper monthly price so I switched
recently next you have to compile the
binary which is also quite easy you're
using the exact same commands as you
would do for for compiling a standard
standard binary the first thing you have
you do is you tell it which of the
compilers you want to use so AFL comes
with I guess six different compilers but
there's a GCC compliant one and then
there's a seal on another sealing fast
which is the LLVM one and that's
generally the best one to use if you can
there's something called AFL
instrumentation radio which
tells it how much instrumentation do you
want to add to your code and usually I
set this to 100% but you might want to
change it if if it's too slow or if it
doesn't find anything for an extended
period of time you could also set AF el
jardín which is also something I
recommend you do because this adds some
some code hardening so we can provoke
crashes quicker so it adds stack
Canaries and things like that
once you found a test corpus which is
what I usually do is if I'm gonna fuss
something I find online I go to the
github repo and I find the test folder
and I grab the files there because
they're usually a good set of test cases
and I use those as the corpus but once
you found that you probably want to
minimize it because the larger files you
have the slower it will go and of course
if you have a lot of files that are
essentially the same that won't help you
either
so atha comes with two tools for you to
use there's something called a FL seaman
where you can you can take a lot of a
list of files within the folder and you
can tell it to minimize this list so it
removes all the things that aren't
interesting and then you can minimize a
certain test case with teaming so you
you basically it will chop off things
and normalize bits and try to figure out
what's the smallest file I can use where
I still get the same code coverage so
it's pretty smart about that as well and
then you can get so a small set of files
which are small and that will make it
run fast once we run the faster on the
top here you see a single faster running
where where you specify the folder name
where you have the test cases you
specify an output folder and then you
can specify options if you want to and
then you specify - - and the binary and
the options - the binary and then the
at-at at the end means that it's going
to take input from a file because you
can also use AFL with input from
standard out if you or a standard a and
I guess if you want that in the second
block here you see me running a fuzzer
in in multi-core mode so or I have a
master which is the one with the - M at
the top which is faster cr1 and then you
can add slaves to it you they all just
have to point to the same directory
three and and that works perfectly as
well and that's probably what he what
you want to do if you if you going to
fuss something that's that's bigger if
it's slow or just generally if you have
enough CPU for it
you can specify some options there are a
lot more of options that you can you can
use but the normal ones are - m4 how
much memory do you want to limit the
each test case to use or each run of the
application to use so it will crash if
use it's using more memory or get an out
of memory you can also specify a timeout
because you don't want it if it's
hanging for extended period of time
maybe you're doing something and and it
goes into a while loop or something that
it never is exits from so you can have a
you can specify how much time what's the
maximum runtime for for each of these
runs or you can just let it figure it
out itself this is the the interface
that you get it's very ASCII or ANSI
maybe I'm gonna get back to this in a
little bit because we're going to do a
demo but that this is basically the way
it looks once you start running it you
get an output folder once one for each
of the faster so if you're running like
a master and three slaves you're gonna
get one folder for each of them in the
output folder and inside there you're
gonna get one folder that's called
crashes this is where inputs that cause
the applications to crash will be you're
going to get one with Hanks that's where
yeah things that cause it to hang and
then the queue is anything that it
hasn't been tried yet the next things
that it will test inside this crashes
folder you'll find a lot of files in
this format it's a bit of an annoying
format to type but what you see here is
like every crash gets an identifier and
then it's there's the exit signal that
it got when it crashed
it's which what was the source branch
and then what kind of operation it was
doing and on which bit it was working on
because if we go back here we can see
some of the strategies that it's using
hair down here so it can do bit flips by
flips or it mythix known in dictionary
and then Havoc
which i guess is just moving things
around and then trim
so it's doing all kinds of stuff there
once we've found some crashes we want to
try edge them figure out what what what
are these crashes actually so what I
normally start doing is then I compiled
a binary once more but without AFL just
with a normal compiler and then I run
the test case with the normal executable
which of course if it doesn't crash
there then it might be something with
the fussing setup that's causing it to
crash but often times it will crash with
the normal binary as well you could use
something like address sanitizer a
memory sanitizer and run it through
there to see what's going on or you
could even use gdb and there's a plugin
called exploitable which is a nice
plugin if I have time I'll show you that
one which we can use to figure out if
this is likely to be something that
would be exploitable from a security
perspective something you can also do
here is use T min once more you can use
that to minimize the test case so if you
want if you have a large file maybe you
want to make it a bit smaller before you
start to or submit it to your your set
of test cases or report it to whoever
wrote the code so profit well if this is
if you're fussing your insertable binary
stuff that you're building yourself of
course reporting it to the to the dev
team or if you are the dev team fix them
and add them as test cases to your
application if this is external software
well you might want to do some kind of
responsible disclosure I was hoping for
this conference to be able to present
some of the stuff that I found but none
of it has been fixed yet so I can't
really talk about that
unfortunately so I'm gonna do a short
demo of afo so what I've done before
before you guys came in here is that
I've I've downloaded FL and compile it
I've downloaded a tool called sassy
which is a sass to CSS converter and
I've download the the downloaded the the
stuff that it needs to
to run or to compile so I'm just going
to compile it first or before that even
I'm gonna here you can see my current
settings up there AFL Harden is set to
one AFL instrumentation radio is set to
100 and then I'm using the C length fast
compiler so I'm going to compile it now
what you'll see here is that it's it's
except from all these warnings you'll
see that it says maybe I can pause it a
bit you'll see that it actually it's
actually you can see that it's using the
correct compiler because you see here
LLVM pass and in the new version of AFL
so you can see that it's printing this
AFL KC line fast down here and it will
also say how many how many we are
instrumentations it was adding so you
can you'll you'll see that eventually so
now I'm just compiling it normally just
like I would with any other compiler and
it shouldn't take too long what I've
also done is I in this this github repo
that I downloaded there was a set of
test cases so let's see
you're clear to get it up on the top so
if we look in in my current folder here
I have actually gonna there is a SAS
spec which is a list of test files and
there's a lot of so called
SAS files in there so I just picked a
set of those I picked those that were in
the basic folder and I put them in a
folder that I've called corpus pre so in
here I have a set of files now I want to
to shorten that list and compress it a
bit so I'm going to use AFL C mini fire
and like this so I'm putting it to the
corpus pre folder that's the folder
where you have the test cases I want its
output into the corpus folder then - -
and then this is the binary and it just
takes a file like this it doesn't take
any other options or it doesn't have to
so I can do like this so now it's going
to
look through all of these files and it's
going to try to figure out which of
these files have similar branches which
of these files are actually giving it
something new and try to reduce the
number of files that it that it needs or
that it recommends that you use as you
see this takes a little bit of time but
it's definitely worth it for later
because we don't want it to sort of run
through all kinds of stuff all over and
over and over and over again and the the
the inputs and outputs that I gave it
already the parameters that I gave it
are exactly the same as for AFL fuss so
yeah there's 66 files and you can see it
still takes a bit of time to run through
it even though it's it's a kind of fight
it's fast enough binary I think but it
takes a bit of time just to work itself
through all of these so for those of you
who don't know what SAS is SAS is a way
of writing CSS but you kind of compile
it to CSS so a browser could understand
it but you write it in a more dense
format and you can have functions and
things like that inside it so you can
call a function and then that would
output some new CSS and this this
library has been first many times before
and people have published results from
fasting it before maybe we'll find
something maybe we won't we'll see
I know if at least a couple of crashes
that I found before so I can show you
just how that looks because I have them
in a folder here should be finished soon
and now it what it's going to tell us
now is how many of these files that we
originally had that it needed so it took
away only five of these so that that was
a pretty decent set of test cases
actually the next next thing that we
want to do is to use a tool to figure
out how much CPU how many foster should
we run and of course AFL comes with the
tool phrase so AFL got CPU we run this
and it's as well four of your course
they are
already busy doing stuff because I'm
running a couple of fosters already on
this server but I have four course
available as well so course six five
four and seven or confessors that I can
use this is pretty practical so you
don't end up running stuff and then it
everything goes slow and then yeah
instead of starting them all one by one
I have created a small script here to
start them because I want to run them
each in the screen so I can disconnect
from the server at any time and they
will keep running so I'm starting a
master fessor called fuzzy one I'm cause
and then I'm starting three slaves for
search two and three and four and I'm
pointing it to the corpus this is where
I'm we just now minified all the test
cases into that folder and it's going to
store its output in output let's start
this and now we can go in and look at
the first buzzer now we get back to this
this screen I'm going to show you a
couple of things that's important here
you can see that it's finding paths up
here at the right side of the screen
here if it doesn't find paths that might
mean that you're running against the non
instrumented binary so you might want to
go back and check double check if you're
actually running it against the compiled
the binary that you compiled with AFL
you should also see here last new path
if this one keeps just going higher and
higher that might mean that it either
already found all the paths or that
you're running against the non
instrumented binary as you can see in
this case it's it's finding a lot of new
paths you can see down here as I
mentioned here you can see the
strategies and you'll see which ones
that yielded new paths here you will see
the execution speed generally that
should be pretty high and we'll get back
to some of the Malaysians and you'd see
the total executions as well up on the
right here you see cycles done that's
how many times has it been running
through all the paths that it's found
and you usually want to stop fussing our
weight with stopping until it's been
running
a few cycles or maybe multiple cycles
because you might run it through one
cycle but then it's going to find new
parts the next time around because it's
it's got a new set of test cases for it
so that's that's it but that's not the
easiest way to figure out because now
we're running we're running four parts
four faster it's not just one and of
course the guys who made a fellas have
thought about that as well so we have a
nice little command called AFL what's up
and we just point it to the to the
output folder that all the fosters are
now using to synchronize so we can do
like this and then we'll see the output
for each fessor fuzzer one is doing this
first or two is doing this and we can
see the speed of each faster and we have
a summary down here so this is the
amount of of executions that it's been
running so far so we'll just leave that
running and come back to it in a in a
while and see if it's found anything and
if it hasn't then I'll show you some
some samples that I already have so
optimization we really want the fussing
to be as fast as possible and we also
want it to crash as fast as possible if
there is something wrong so anything
that we can do to make it crash if it
tries to do things that it shouldn't if
it tries to read outside a buffer if we
try to write outside a buffer if it
tries to read or write stuff that it's
already freed etc we want it to crash
and we want it to be fast so the the
first thing we do is of course to use
these tools to minimize the test cases
and if we have large inputs we generally
want to try to remove stuff if we can
because it's going to be slow in some
cases we might want to isolate the code
that we're testing let's say we have a
large application and the code that
we're really interested in fussing is
just a tiny part of it maybe we have a
parser of some kind somewhere in the
code we can break that out and just
write a small wrapper around it and then
test that instead so we don't have to
like bring up the whole system if that's
if that's a big thing for you but at the
LLVM mode comes with some clever trick
tricks
what AFL will do is it will try as good
as possible to start the binary and it
will find a point in time where things
that okay this is where I'm going to
start fussing from and then it will make
a copy of itself so it doesn't have to
do the initialization again and again
and again but you can help it and tell
it where it should stop if you want to
by adding this this will tell AFL that
when you come to this point this is
where you can make a copy and then for
the next execution you just bring you
just use this piece of memory and then
run it again so we have a fork server
basically you could also use something
called LLVM persistent mode and this is
something that can be useful for let's
say you have a a petition that takes a
really long time to start up and then
there's a small piece that you want to
test but you can't really isolate it in
any clever way you could do something
like this you can add a loop to it and
then you have to make sure that you read
the input data do the stuff that needs
to be first and then you reset the state
cleverly inside there by yourself
and this will make it a lot faster of
course because now we can do a lot of
fussing on a single single process AFL
also comes with something called Lib
dislocator
live this locator is a drop-in for the
ellipse e alligator and what it's going
to do is quite clever it's going to add
these guard pages around everything that
you allocate in your code so if you if
you allocate a piece of on the heap it's
gonna add a guard page so it's going to
allocate it just next to a guard page so
if you try to read outside this piece of
heap that you've allocate it is going to
crash because it's going to hit the
guard page similarly if you free
something it's going to mark that as a
guard page so you can't really go back
and read something that you're already
freed and so it adds a lot of these
things to your codes the problem with
using this locator is that a lot of
binaries they just won't work when you
add it because I don't know they're
doing things that they shouldn't already
so when you try to start AFL with live
dislocator it might just crash
immediately and it's just going to
crashing and/or it's gonna say I can't
really start this in a proper way
because it keeps on crashing but it's a
clever it's really useful for
applications where it actually works and
it's it probably works for a lot of
things I just had it crash a lot lately
with things that are fast so I've had to
run without it for some time you can
also add dictionaries and these are this
is an example dictionary from from the
github repo where you can add stuff that
so it doesn't have to discover
everything itself so you could either
have a directory full of files with
tokens in them or you can just have a
single file with key value pairs and
generally it's going to ignore the names
it's just gonna use the the values and
you can hex encode stuff that's not
ASCII so as you can see at the bottom
there this can also help it to become
faster so when I when I'm now fussing
this sass compiler I could have added
stuff that was common in a you know in a
sass or CSS file to help it along this
can be useful if if needed so first
thing is not an excuse for writing bad
code of course but it might help you
detect that your written bad code or
that your colleagues a written bad code
or that someone else I've written a bad
library so it can be useful to maybe
fuss libraries that you have first your
own code first things that just
generally first stuff it's it's fun this
is a slide from Patricia Oz she did a
talk at NDC oslo called secure program
practices in c++ where she brought up a
lot of things that we should do and one
of them was i'd really rather you didn't
use pointers a lot and i've first quite
a lot of applications and i've seen a
lot of as I said I know no C or C++
programmer but I've seen a lot of code
that looks kind of iffy when you look at
it with lots of pointers and things
going around and then you seem like more
modern C++ like Patricia is recommending
you write and when I first these things
I generally find of course a lot more
bugs in the poetry code stuff than in
the properly written C C++ modern stuff
that she's recommending so
there's a big truth to this so let's go
back to the fuzzer now and see what's
going on it might not have found
anything probably not because it hasn't
been running for a very long time so
says our fuzzers are still alive but it
hasn't found any crashes yet okay of
course I prepared for this so I have a
folder here called
output 2 which is a folder of some
crashes that I found earlier so we have
all our four fosters here let's go into
faster first one and see what's going on
in there we'll see that in the crashes
folders folder there are a good set of
crashes in here what you see all the way
to the bottom here is a readme file what
that file tells you is what kind of
command was being run where when were
you were creating this crash so you see
here this is the this is the command on
the center of the screen so you can
easily okay what was I doing when I
found this crash ok I was running the
faster like this ok that's fine so let's
look at one of these crashes
so there it looks like kind of a normal
file the thing I'm reacting to here is
that there's like a variable and then
the percentage up there that looks a bit
odd and it says there's a flip of
something in a early place in the code
so maybe there's something wrong here
let's see
so I mentioned exploitable so what we
can do then is we can open up the the
binary in gdb and then we can run it
against this let's see if I can find my
mouse pointer there it is we can run it
against this file and it's in the output
oops output to folder like this and we
run it and we see we get a segmentation
fault down here what we can do then is
to use this so-called exploitable plug
in 4 for gdb so I have that flying
around here of course you can download
it from github it's a bit let's see here
it's a Python script that you just
import like this and then you can run
exploitable so now it tells me what was
happening it's an access violation
during a branch instruction and it says
exploitability classification
exploitable so this might be a good find
for someone who wants to attack this
this binary of course this is a binary
that you usually run locally on your
server so it it's not really a big
problem maybe but but if this was like
like a an image parser or something that
would parse data coming in from a
network that might be a big problem so
see what's going on now did it find
anything no it didn't okay
this is generally the way I use it I set
up the fuzzers
and I I go in and check regularly to see
what's going on of course now it's just
been running for for a short period of
time but if it was running for
I usually leave it running for quite a
few days to get the cycle counter I'm
going to show you one more thing if we
go into one of these odd slave fuzzers
Dame out if it might have found more
paths
let's see compare this this one has 3000
this one has let's see that wasn't the
same one
sorry there we go so this one has over
4,000 paths so they're doing a bit it
working a bit in a different way or
doing different different type of
fussing strategies so our in a different
order so it might find things faster and
usually you'll see that the slave
Buster's they will go they will cycle
faster because they're not doing the
full thing while the master faster is
trying to go through everything and then
it will generally take a lot longer to
to go through one cycle I normally wait
until the master faster has been running
for maybe five ten cycles before I quit
well the the slavers are they might have
run like 40 cycles or something like
that generally you want the execution
speed to be quite high so a thousand
executions per second or over 500
executions per second that's fine
actually if you run something that's
really slow AFL will tell you and it
will be like a snoring sign next to the
execution speed and this is a slow
binary we're actually say so under
startup as well so what I'm hoping by by
doing this talk for you is that this
will get you into fussing and I hope
I've shown you that it's not really that
hard to get started it's actually quite
easy I was kind of surprised because you
don't have to know that much to get
started that's what I was dreading when
I first like okay I'm gonna start
fussing but I don't know anything about
it what do I need to know to start and
it's it's not that much some resources
that you might find useful there's a
blog post from foxglove security called
fussing works flow a first job from
start to finish which kind of goes
through the running the minification of
test cases and all that kind of stuff
others to good talks from from one from
rusik this year
1.the from Craig Jung the one that I
quoted earlier is which is from 2016 and
these at least the the b-sides talked it
goes a bit deeper into how the how the
instrumentation works while the one from
2018 ADA actually explains how you can
fuss Windows binaries and not just Linux
binaries so in summary I think fuzzing
is quite easy to get started with and it
can be really useful for making robust
applications and if you're fussing other
stuff it might even earn you a bug
bounty questions yes yep
so the input files are I was using our
actual files from from the test cases
for the the binary down testing so I
went to the github repo I grabbed a set
of test files and I used that as an
input and that kind of primes the fuzzer
so it makes it start fuzzing properly
sooner but you could have used like a
hello file like like Michael did with
JPEG for sir parser you could just use
like an empty file if that's what you
need but it's generally better to have a
good set of test cases because that
makes it or puts it faster into a place
where it can start finding stuff no you
could but I mean the way FL works is
that it takes some input and sends it
into the application and then sees what
happens so you need some way to like
invoke the application and that's
usually for a file or a three standard
in so if you're fussing something I
don't know if you're fussing something
that where you can't like give it a file
or give it some some input and make it
processes then it might be hard a bit
harder to fuzz it
[Music]
right so there are there are other smart
processors in AFL so I'm introducing AFL
here but there are a lot of other
Fosters as well and some of them are
faster at doing other stuff and some of
them are you might find in a case where
they're much faster than than AFL for
instance the Michael or I think it was
Michael Sulu ski who went back after
both or at least after heart beat and
figured out how they could have found
heartbeat using fuzzing and then without
actually knowing anything about the
heartbeat functionality that cost
Hartley but it wasn't found originally
using AFL but it could have been found I
[Music]
would do it or I wouldn't run it as a
part of a normal build pipeline because
it takes a lot of time so I would rather
say this is something that you you you
fuss binary's at a pace like once every
it depends on how long it takes for you
to get enough cycles but maybe maybe you
fuzz every if you're releasing a new
version every day
you can't fuss them all because it takes
it might take more than a day it might
take a week to fuss properly but like I
would just continuously fuss and then
when I when I release a new version I
would wait a bit because I want to
previous faster to start but then I'll
start fussing the newest binary from
there on so it's something I would do
continuously but I wouldn't do it as a
part of a normal CI pipeline other
questions
I think stalk and look at the throw
towards the end he has some he has some
some statistics from stuff that he's
done to optimize stuff where you can see
that he goes he he at least gets double
the speed and more than that but it it
will take well it depends on the size of
the binary the number of branches like
there's no good answer
sorry so how well organized are the the
fastest when you run multiple of them so
they don't run in the same case well I
think they're pretty well organized I
don't really have a good answer for it
but it seems to me that they find
different crashes from the different
buzzers so it seems to work pretty well
because they're using this output folder
as a sync folder so they kind of write
stuff there for the queue and then they
pick stuff out you can even you could
even I've seen setups from this where
you can run it across multiple nodes so
you could have but then you have to copy
the sync folder or sink the sink fold
basically between the nodes at a certain
pace but there's there are scripts for
that as well I have never tried it I've
just run it on a single node
[Music]
I'm not sure what I when I got into this
I started because of this training where
they were fussing nodejs native binaries
so it's section so that there you had
what I would do then is I compiled
nodejs
with instrumentation radio set to zero
because is because you need to compile
it with with AFL but then you don't want
to instrument note itself because I
wanted to actually test these these
libraries so what I did then I compiled
nodejs and then I had a small JavaScript
that was just like pulling in a file and
calling the library and then I compiled
the library itself with AFL but it still
was C and C++ so I don't know if you can
you could probably Foss Java itself but
I know I don't know if you could fast
like a java application because I think
you would still faster runtime and not
the actual application I don't know if
that answered your question good
question I don't I don't actually know
the internals of AFL so I need more
questions yes
all right thank you for coming
[Applause]